let me take you someplace special I'm
leaving you in charge we're good rest
easy lovebirds
it happens when you suppress your powers
I can't trust myself
let's try this
so this is
time to pay a house call
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my flash season 6 episode 5
trailer video I'll address the Easter
eggs and the crisis on Infinite Earths
scenes from episode 4 and also all the
Green Lantern stuff I have a new Green
Lantern theory about crisis on Infinite
Earths based on all the news of the new
Green Lantern stuff that they're working
on we'll do a giveaway for either Green
Lantern Corps rings or flash rings
either one all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
Green Lantern Corps theory for the
arrowverse on the video just addressing
the footage and the easter eggs then
I'll talk about Green Lantern stuff even
though the Cisco promo is black and
white I'm not positive whether or not
next week's episode is going to be full
black and white because it seems like
Barry and iris are going on vacation so
cisco is in charge but he's having all
these weird hallucinations because he's
suppressing his powers as breacher says
so the man danny trejo is back i always
love it when danny trejo is around
they've been using it for so much comedy
in previous seasons though but that was
meant to be more comedic season and
they're a little bit more serious
because of all the crisis stuff this
year you see him jumping Cisco a couple
times trying to scare him maybe he's
trying to force him to use his powers
everybody saw Cisco wearing his vibe
costume in the flash-forward to the
crisis scenes during episode 2 so I feel
like it was only going to be a matter of
time before he either got his powers
back or he found a way around that so
that he could still do superhero stuff
during the big crossover episodes but
the big crisis scenes from last week's
episode Nash wells needed a special
crypto circuit for what we actually
found out was trying to track the path
of the monitor oh this is where you've
been hiding so he's actually looking for
the eternium which i think is also tied
to the iris west secretly being from the
future storyline which is a big deep cut
for the flash comic books I'll talk
about that in a second - he's meant to
be this intergalactic debunker of God
myth themes so it sounds like he's
meddling in affairs pariah style if
you're a big comic book crisis on
Infinite Earths fan in him busting into
this space where the monitor has been
either keeping things or one of his
special sanctums is going to push him on
the path to becoming the comic book
pariah the person in the very pariah
looking costume during the crossover
scenes they were filming on the
Waverider
there was no confirmation that that was
going to be nash wells because we
haven't heard him speak it's just a
picture
so you just have to imagine which
version of Harrison wells that's going
to be back when they announced crisis
they said that he would be playing
pariah but he'd also be a new version of
wells and he'd be coming back as
reverse-flash for the crossover so at
the time I assumed that that man he was
playing three different versions of the
character but if nash wells becomes
pariah that would make a little more
sense and he just be playing two
different characters it wouldn't get
that crazy the whole idea of a pariah
being an outsider someone who's
unwelcome also ties in with what he said
about the Council of wells like when
Cisco referenced it he said oh those
jackasses like he doesn't want have
anything to do with the other versions
of himself the version of that character
in the comics was turned into pariah
sort of got his powers or was cursed
with his powers to serve the monitor
after he meddled in Affairs that alerted
the anti-monitor to the presence of the
positive matter universe setting off
comic-book crisis on Infinite Earths so
he was the one that was to blame for all
the deaths and destruction of the
universes the whole thing with iris West
secretly being from the future in the
comics is just sort of way to bring her
back because reverse-flash in the
classic Silver Age comics her at
a costume party while she's dressed up
like Batgirl later they wanted to bring
the character back so they said that she
was secretly from the 30th century and
her parents the real parents from the
30th century sent her backwards in time
so that she would be safe there
after a reverse flash bond of
her they took her life force and put her
consciousness inside a new body
reuniting Barry and iris in the future
but they only had a month together
before 1985 in real life in crisis on
Infinite Earths in the comics happened
where they really did off the flash
the TV show will probably have a
different way of explaining why she was
from the future and why she was sent
back into the past and why everyone
thinks that she's Joe's daughter when
really she might be the daughter of
someone in the 30th century most of this
past week's episode was dedicated to
just Barry getting Cisco ready to being
team leader when he's gone assuming that
he's got obviously we don't think the
flash is going to die because the show
is going to continue in the back half of
the season and they're still calling it
the flash so it's kind of a moot point
but I did like when Cisco dropped that
little teaser can this serum protect
someone from antimatter in Nashville
says obviously yes it totally can they
also dropped a deep cut Easter Egg for
the dominators during the invasion
crossover from a cup
years ago because apparently McCullough
Tech which is an Easter Egg for mirror
master went to the dominators homeworld
to steal that serum if he didn't see the
arrow episode this week they also
referenced a lot of monitor and
anti-monitor stuff they're sort of
setting up the concept of the
anti-monitor because the monitor Mar
Nauvoo has not told them about his
counterpart from the antimatter universe
there was a book that belonged to an
ancient member of the League of
Assassins that was kept in a tomb they
did a big riff on the season three
midseason finale when all Oliver was
or seemingly killed by Ra's al Ghul
and then kicked off the
mountaintop so the whole episode was
made to reference that episode they
brought thea back and then the person
that wrote the book chronicled that the
monitor was worried that he would be the
one to bring the destruction the crisis
on Infinite Earths so Oliver is going
into this thinking that the monitor
might turn on them but based on the look
of him inside this book it looks more
like the anti-monitor the monitor also
brought future team arrow Mia and all
the future people into present-day in
the arrow cave with Oliver because we've
seen pictures of them behind the scenes
during the crossover so we knew that she
was going to participate in crisis on
Infinite Earths so she would be on
screen with Oliver and it was just a
matter of which sci-fi twist they would
use to explain how they accomplished
that obviously it would be a version of
time travel but the monitor basically
snapped his fingers and brought them
together
what's going on
that's a very good question
getting into the Green Lantern stuff so
new theory about Green Lantern
during crisis on Infinite Earths
everybody wants Green Lantern in the air
over somewhere but they just announced
the Greg Berlanti of the Berlanti verse
of course is doing a new Green Lantern
series on HBO max and they're trying to
tie all the disparate shows together
using crisis on Infinite Earths they've
got Black Lightning crossing over
previously they said that that wasn't
connected to the arrow verse but it's
definitely going to be connected now
there's rumors that they're also trying
to tie the Titans universe on the DC
streaming service to the arrow verse
using crisis as well they've been
teasing Diggle Green Lantern Easter eggs
for several seasons on arrow now
everyone at fan cast him is Jon Stewart
of the arrow burrs and recently they
actually canonized the idea that his
real name is Stewart so he has a
stepfather named general Stewart that
married his mother
so technically John diggle's real name
is John Diggle Stewart now during crisis
on Infinite Earths they've been filming
we saw a big battle scene it clearly
looks like his Spartan costume has very
large green highlights on it that it did
not have before even if he doesn't
actually wear a Green Lantern core ring
during the crossover the shows will
probably reference Green Lantern Corps
in some way I don't expect them to
actually have Hal Jordan or another
really big Green Lantern comic book
character like Jon Stewart in the
crossover but just the idea that the
Green Lantern Corps exists and is
currently active then they'll save the
task of introducing those Green Lantern
characters like Hal Jordan and the other
big ones during the actual Green Lantern
series when it premieres on HBO max in a
couple years I will do a separate video
about the Green Lantern series tomorrow
because there's so many Ryan Reynolds
jokes that we could make about this but
it also means that they're probably not
going to do the Green Lantern reboot movie that they had talked about before a lot
of you been wondering how they're going to top crisis on Infinite Earths with a
crossover next year well they could use
it as a big Green Lantern Corps
introduction and then they debut on
their TV show because I don't think
that's going to premiere until 2021 and
typically they use the crossovers to
introduce really really big comic book
characters so everybody let me know in
the comments what do you think they're
going to do with Green Lantern stuff during
crisis on Infinite Earths I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post that new
Green Lantern video tomorrow but
everyone click here
to learn about the big Avengers 5
announcement in Young Avengers and click
here for the teaser for the brand-new
Game of Thrones prequel series thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!